casimir
casimir je suis prêt où es tu allez
c'est l'heure de partir
moi tu pu passer
lettre m qu'est ce que c'est que mon
cher léonard
monsieur bon chaîne m'a proposé de venir
passer la journée avec lui en bateau
je trouve ça plus amusant que d'aller
pêcher la crevette avec toi signait
casimir
jeter zut et zut ce krasimir ruse n'est
qu'un sale égoïste
très bien ah c'est vous monsieur du ce
nombre vous tombez mal mais au contraire
lui n'a au contraire je tombe très bien
eh bien allez plutôt tombé sur casimir
c'est ce qui me fera le plus plaisir à
traquer l'humour bravo bon c'est tout ce
qu'est une campagne électorale
une campagne électorale
oui
une campagne avec des moutons pas du
tout
une campagne avec des shows non à mettre
des vaches encore moins léonard une
campagne électorale et l'ensemble des
réunions discours et visites que fait
une personne qui se présente aux
élections afin de convaincre le plus de
gens possible de voter pour elle
et tu n'es pas sans savoir que ce soir
on doit élire le nouveau président de la
fête de l'île aux enfants je croyais que
c'était vous le président de la fin de
l'hymne aux enfants wilona mais jusqu'à
ce soir tu vois et ce soir je laisserai
ma place à mon successeur à moins que
les habitants de l'île aux enfants
décident que grâce à mon savoir mon
intelligence vous laisse pourrir et bien
que je mérite d'être élu nouveau
président de la fête de l'île aux
enfants mais je tombe est peut-être et
tu as déjà décidé de voter pour casimir
mois sûrement pas après ce qu'il m'a
fait
bravo léonard a tu me réchauffe le coeur
je suis heureux que tu me donnes ta voix
très bien je te laisse pas ce que j'ai
d'autres visiteurs fin à bientôt mais
monsieur juste non je n'ai jamais dit ça
jamais salut léonard en bonjour facteur
1 je suis très content de voir
asseyez-vous à l'instant si j'étais
seulement venu de saluer ouais si c'est
important cc c'est très important je
t'écoute
je viens d'apprendre par monsieur du
snob de l'élection du président de la
fête a lieu ce soir eh ben c'est la pure
vérité bon mais casimir est parti en
bateau et il ne peut pas faire sa
campagne électorale comme monsieur du
snob personne ne va voter pour lui ce n
a aucune importance léonard comment vous
dites ça en riant facture mais je
croyais casimir été votre ami pour sûr
je te répète ça ça n'a aucune importance
ce matin j'ai vu casimir qui partait en
bateau avec monsieur beauchesne alors je
lui ai crié casimir chez le jour des
élections il m'a répondu
devine ce qu'il m'a répondu j'ai horreur
des devinettes facteurs mauvais il m'a
répondu je m'en fiche je ne veux plus
être président vous aurez dessus
absolument sûr quand je te vois tient
mais mais mais alors monsieur du snob
sera à nouveau président a pour sûr
il n'y a pas d'autre candidat
[Rires]
désormais il y en a
c'est sûr ça serait trop force
et vous traîne aussi les snobs enfin
prête un break parfait alors vous
parlerez aux premiers instants du savs à
léona oui un peu près tu sais mais je
n'ai jamais fait de discours 1
alors n'ai pas peur écoute bien ce que
dit monsieur du snob et du verra ça se
passera à merveille j'espère
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs voici
les discours des deux candidats à la
présidence tout d'abord le candidat
sortant monsieur du snob
je veux pas sortir avant d'avoir fait
mon discours
on appelle le candidat sortant le
candidat qui occupait le poste
précédemment année dernière vous étiez
président de la fed de l'île aux enfants
oui vous êtes donc le candidat sortant a
rassuré france à travers
mes chers
mais très cher mais très très très cher
allez
merci
depuis que je suis président de la fed
de l'île aux enfants tout s'est toujours
bien passé
chaque fête fut d'une grande réussite
et toujours grâce à moi
si vous voulez que ça continue il n'y a
pas de mesure se marrent
minyana coastal il faut voter pour moi
les verts en scène death note d' avance
merci
[Musique]
merci beaucoup
[Rires]
voici maintenant avant de nouveaux
candidats
bravo
merci à vous mes chers amis
depuis que monsieur du ce nombre est
président de la fête peut ni nos enfants
tout s'est mal passé
chaque fête fut un grand et chaque est
toujours à cause de lui si vous voulez
que ça change il n'y a pas plusieurs
chemins mais un seul il faut que vous
votiez pour léonard avant
je suis me please et
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
leonard calme-toi
qu'est ce que ça sera tout à l'heure
quand le vote commence à ranger unis je
sais je sais mais écoute j'ai envoyé
françois et le vainqueur de monde hier
beaucoup d'habitants de l'île pour qui
ils vont voter comme ça je saurai si
j'ai des chances d'être élu que tu te
comprends cela s'appelle un sondage un
sondage
alors je vais faire un sondage par
françois est le facteur et il ne devrait
plus tarder maintenant en promets moi de
rester calme quoi qu'il dise
tu es sûr et très libre bon ce tous les
gens qui nous avons posé la question on
déclaré tu voterais pour toi tu sais que
ton discours a été très apprécié et
c'est formidable et là tu vas être
président
formidable silence silence à ses
silences mes amis silence
je suis très
fier et amusez vous
j'ai interrogé quelques enfants pour
savoir pour qui les allées voter ce soir
ah bon vous si vous avez fait un petit
sondage ouais rien catastrophe ce soir
je ne serai plus président oui
d'ailleurs tiens leona
avant les élections je te rapporter les
droits et devoirs de coupe des
présidents vous messieurs
je vous rendre hommage dans mon premier
disque ou merci julie voyons ça droit du
président très bien le président a le
droit d'être président hu à
devoir du président att des gens alors
le président doit s'occuper d'organiser
la fête de limiter la place des stands
de vérifier la livraison des provisions
d'assurer les comptes de chacun des
stands de calculer les deux
ohlala ohlala je me sens fort très bien
oh là là je suis fatigué je ne veux plus
être président en non non non non non je
vote je veux pour monsieur du snob
[Musique]